well scotland and ukraine are set for an
emotional clash when they meet at
hampton park in tonight's world cup
playoff the game will be ukraine's first
match since russia launched its invasion
in february whoever wins will face wales
on sunday for a place in qatar joining
me now from edinburgh is our scotland
correspondent james matthews and and
james this is being
dubbed scotland versus the world but of
course both sides want to win but a lot
of people uh backing ukraine too
yeah scotland are favorites uh you're
watching me through the windscreen of
one of two coaches here high above
edinburgh the ukrainian club is down the
road the pipes are playing and something
like a hundred ukrainian refugees have
come here
most with tickets uh to be passed
through to watch the game ivan you came
here seven years ago in scotland
there's a lot of talk about what this
game means what does it mean to you as a
ukrainian well to me personally this
game means uh just a chance to support
ukraine to show
that we love our country we never let
our country alone and we're going to be
supporting
our country
ivan thanks very much indeed robbie ross
on the pipes thanks robbie that's grand
many people going to this game came to
the uk only weeks ago
and we're going to speak to a couple of
them now
um
hello uh natalia yeah uh
tell me to tell you you're going to the
game
what does this game mean to you
first of all it's part of our country
for me
we are not at home now and it means a
lot to see our ukrainian team i'm not a
fan for you
it's my second match in my life
so
i even
can't explain what it means it means a
lot it's my people they are my people
it's my country and of course
we are looking
uh for peace
for safety
and
this is a little
part of peace
a peaceful life
so
people you know
in ukraine
where are they watching the game of
course
our
men especially
they offend a lot of fans in ukraine
and they will stay because the
difference in time is two hours so it's
late in ukraine here they will stay as
long as it will take
thank you rob thank you very much
natalia roxanna hello there um hi uh
when did you come here timbre uh i'm
from leave
from ukraine i live here in edinburgh
i'm really glad that and today i can
support my country uh here
and uh i go to glasgow and i will
support ukraine glory to ukraine
at this time what does this match mean
to ukraine um means a lot and um my
husband and my friends really
glad when we they hear that i'm can see
in like in with my eyes this match uh
this uh this like competition and you
know um
i know this this first match after uh
the invasion after 20th uh
24th of february and yeah it's it's a
lot of emotions
uh i'm overwhelmed with emotions today
and just yeah i will be support and
it's nice
what is the emotion is it a glimpse of
normality somehow it's a little bit like
really destruction of
it's like small small destruction of
what's going on right now and just like
remember like remind us uh how it can be
like simple peaceful life when you just
um just go to some events like
like football like concert like
different kind of events that we used to
have in our previous lives yeah thank
you very much indeed and can we can we
ask you hi
what's your name um valeria hello
valyria um what does this game mean to
you it means a lot because it's not a
mesh it's not a football match it's more
about
to country which scottish very supports
us and ukraine
in such situation
it
means a lot for us
when did you come here from cave
and what are people back home doing are
they watching the match what does it
mean to them of course they are watching
uh their won uh our
victory but
this match is more than victory what is
it what is it what's more than victory
it's friendly atmosphere
you won't get any argument with that now
let's very briefly speak to the scottish
contingent at the front of the coach um
hello there hi you're dressed in the
scottish hats ukrainian tops and you're
hosting refugees here in scotland uh
tell me it's a tricky one is it for
scots you know
support for ukraine and yet support for
scotland tonight yes it is hard i mean
clearly we want scotland to win as
always but that one time we're so close
to world cup qualification there is that
past person thinking
ukraine could win as well i know it
wouldn't be a bad thing so uh yeah i
don't think we we weren't going to win
but
wouldn't we be a win-win yes definitely
absolutely
okay well thank you very much indeed um
whoever wins tonight of course there
will be the rematch actually will be two
rematches scotland playing ukraine in
the nation's league later
this year so big occasion tonight big
crowd big expectations big emotions